almost inevitably somewhere along the
path of our friendships we are fated to
stumble upon one of the most paradoxical
yet Universal of characters the envious
friend
at one level this person is kind
sympathizes with us in our sorrows and
believes that they want the best for us
yet despite such salutary affections we
may not be able to overlook some more
troubling Dynamics shimmering beneath
the surface when we invite them for
dinner they repeatedly forget to say
thank you when we have a new partner
they don't appear overly pleased when we
get a new job they don't ask us a single
question about how it's going
the situation can be as wounding as it
is Uncharted how we going to cope can
this be happening to us
you ways forwards suggest themselves
firstly we shouldn't ever compound the
matter by denying that it might exist or
wander for too long whether we might be
imagining things we're not those
silences missing questions and strange
looks mean exactly what we suspect they
mean of course there is Envy we
shouldn't expect any bond of friendship
to be without at least one important
degree of this ubiquitous feeling
the reasons for this are self-evident we
tend to be friends with people who share
our aspirations and values and therefore
it's highly likely that at some point
along our journey together either they
will acquire something we very much want
or vice versa it might be a partner a
profession a qualification or a home but
it will be something for sure we envy
people for the same reason as we're
friends with them
like the same sorts of things
we're unhelfully inclined to be
sentimental and therefore dishonest on
this score we often deny that we could
possibly Harbor Envy for someone that we
also like which can lead us to
unconvincing denials and cuts off
opportunities for processing and growth
we need to learn to feel better about
Envy in order not to have to twist our
characters to avoid admitting to it we
should with reasonable good cheer simply
own up to our Envy as we would to a sore
knee or an ulcer children can be good
guides in this area an average
four-year-old is comedically open about
their ravenous jealousy they don't
contort themselves into knots in the
name of politeness they will immediately
when their friend gets a better fire
truck or try to hit them over the head
or gouge out their eyes
parents tend to be so shocked by this
they force the child into fruitless
denials they Inspire them to hide their
Envy from two people
firstly the person they're envious of
and secondly and far worse from
themselves they implicitly teach their
offspring a pernicious and untrue idea
that you cannot both be a nice person
and envy your friend and therefore
tragically in adult friendships neither
party is left able to call out the
problem sensibly or deal with it
maturely leaving it to fester in
embarrassment and shame instead
this brings us to the second solution to
envying friendships we should go in for
Mutual playful non-pejorative moments of
confession all good friends should in an
entirely good-natured way routinely
discuss the presence of Envy between
them the question shouldn't be whether
or not there is Envy just what sort of
Envy it might be this week
friends should for example over dinner
each write on a sheet of paper would I'm
envious of now and then they should
laugh with great compassion at the
results
an important part of the reason why we
don't process Envy as we might is that
we imagine there to be only one solution
to the emotion that the person who has
something that their friend lacks is
going to have to hand it over but of
course we can't be expected to surrender
our partner our house or our position
near the top of the company just to make
our old friend feel better however
that's not remotely necessary because
what the person who envies us really
wants is not in the end our love life or
accommodation or profession what they
want above anything else is reassurance
they want to know that we still love
them despite our new advantages they
crave to be told that though we've won
the Lottery sold our shares or found a
dazzling lover we remain deeply attached
to them and care for them as much as we
ever did
unfortunately owning up to our true
longing and hearing it appeased is
devilishly hard for a sequence of reason
that we're now in a position to
appreciate because the envious person
can't admit to what they're feeling
because there aren't generally any good
occasions on which confessions can be
made and because we aren't collectively
schooled in the art of offering
reassurance to others in the wake of our
successes
in a better world we would take greater
Care As a matter of course every time
something went well for us we would be
sure to add in ample reassurance that
despite our new status we will continue
to love and cherish our friends as we
always have
we should stop worrying that there might
be seams of Envy entangled in our
friendships and we should focus instead
on a far more important goal learning to
handle Envy with kindness honesty
intelligence and a fair bit of laughter
too